Fifth grade-- it was so long ago. Who can remember that far back? Two whole years.
五年级——那已经是好久以前的事了。谁还能记得那么久远的事情呢？整整两年啊。
I remember all of, like, the old things. Like we used to read the book Harry Potter when it first came out. And we made curtains.
我记得所有那些旧事物。比如我们曾经在《哈利·波特》刚出版时就读过，还亲手做了窗帘。
Harry Potter curtains.
哈利·波特窗帘。
And they have new curtains now. And I look back at them, and I'm like, wow, you know? It's changed. And I wish it was still there somehow.
现在换了新窗帘了。我回想起从前，心想，哇，你知道吗？一切都变了。我真希望它还能以某种方式保留在那里。
This is Kayla Hernandez, in seventh grade at the Pulaski School in Chicago. She says that she actually visits her fifth grade classroom, Room 211, and her fifth grade teacher, Mrs. Chan, fairly often, and reminisces about the past.
这是凯拉·埃尔南德斯，芝加哥普拉斯基学校七年级的学生。她说她经常回到五年级的教室——211教室，去看望她的五年级老师陈老师，并回忆过去。
Recently I went through the shelves, and our books are still there. Like Our America.
最近我翻了翻书架，我们的书还在那里。比如《我们的美国》。
You're talking about the book Our America?
你是指《我们的美国》那本书吗？
Yeah. You know, reminiscing about when we used to read that book. And how it showed lots of racism.
是的。你知道，回想起我们以前读那本书的时候。它展现了许多种族歧视的内容。
Back in fifth grade, she covered her copy of the book with one of those paper book covers with a picture of NSync on it. It was her copy, though they're not allowed to write their name in the front of the books at her school.
五年级的时候，她用那种印有“超级男孩”（NSync）组合照片的纸质书皮包着她的书。那是她自己的书，尽管在她的学校里，学生们是不允许在书的扉页写名字的。
They had numbers, and my number, I think, was like 30.
书上有编号，我想我的编号大概是30号。
So you did find book number 30?
所以你真的找到了30号书？
Yeah. I did. I saw the book and it was just there, without its paperback covering. You know, everything that was mine is not mine anymore. I think that's the hardest thing from switching to another grade, and to another classroom and to another teacher. And there's a new environment and different things to learn, and old memories to leave behind.
嗯，找到了。我看到了那本书，它就静静地躺在那里，没有了纸质书皮。你知道，曾经属于我的一切现在都不再属于我了。我觉得从一个年级转到另一个年级、换到另一个教室、换到另一位老师，这是最难接受的事情。这里有新的环境，有不同的东西要学，还有必须留下的旧回忆。
20 years from now, 30 years from now, when you try to remember back to seventh grade, what do you think you're going to remember from this year?
20年或30年后，当你试图回想七年级时，你觉得你还会记得这一年的什么事情？
I think I'll remember barely anything.
我觉得我几乎什么都不会记得了。
Isn't that kind of strange, though, to think that you're going through all these experiences now that somehow are going to get wiped off the blackboard?
但想到你现在经历的所有这些体验，到头来都会像黑板上的粉笔字一样被擦掉，这难道不奇怪吗？
Yeah. But I even have that experience now. Like I can't remember things from like second grade. Like some things. Like, I remember this kid, he wrote this Valentine card for me, like, you're pretty as a rose. I don't know. Something like that. But I can't remember teachers really well like I used to.
是啊。但我现在就有这种感觉。比如我无法想起二年级时的一些事情。有些事我记得，比如有个男孩给我写过一张情人节卡片，写着“你美如玫瑰”之类的话。我不知道，大概是那样吧。但我没法像过去那样清楚地记得老师们了。
Do you feel sad about that, or is that OK?
你对此感到难过，还是觉得这很正常？
I feel said about that. Because it's a part of me. It's like you don't even remember what's happened. It's kind of hard. Because it's been a part of you.
我感到难过。因为那是构成我的一部分。就像你甚至不记得发生过什么一样。这很难受，因为它曾经是你的一部分。
When I asked Kayla which friends that she wouldn't remember at all someday, it wasn't hard for her to answer.
当我问凯拉未来她会完全记不起哪些朋友时，她很快就回答了出来。
Cynthia. I'll probably forget Alileni. I'll probably forget Diana and Maria. I'll forget Erica Sorio. I'll forget a whole bunch of people.
辛西娅。我可能还会忘了阿利莱尼。我也可能会忘了戴安娜和玛丽亚。我会忘了埃里卡·索里奥。我会忘了很多人。
She's not close to these kids or anything. But as she said their names, it was like watching them vaporize or something. Someday they'd just be gone, erased from the history of her life, like they had never been there in the first place.
她和这些孩子并不是很亲近。但当她说出这些名字时，看着他们消失，就像看着他们蒸发了一样。总有一天，他们会彻底消失，从她的人生历史中抹去，仿佛他们从来没有出现过一样。
We forget most of everything, and then sometimes we go back and try to remember. And really, there is no predicting which people and places and moments we'll be able to get back. Diana and Maria? They could still make the cut.
我们忘记了几乎所有事情，然后偶尔回头试图回想。实际上，谁也无法预料我们能找回哪些人、哪些地方和哪些瞬间。戴安娜和玛丽亚？她们也许还能留在我记忆里。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Return to Childhood. What you find and what you do not find when you go back.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是“重返童年”。当你回去时，你会发现什么，又会错过什么。
Our show today in four acts. Act one. Once More, With Feeling. In which Jonathan Katz answers the age old question, what happens if you return to your childhood home and it's not so nice, and the current owner tries to sell it to you?
今天的节目分为四个篇章。第一幕：再来一次，带着感情。乔纳森·卡茨回答了一个老生常谈的问题：如果你回到童年的家，却发现它不那么美好，而且现任房主还试图把它卖给你，会发生什么？
Act two. Punk In a Grey Flannel Suit In which a mortgage broker discovers that his old punk band from the '70s is hot in Japan and decides to leave corporate life for a little bit and go back on tour.
第二幕：身穿灰色法兰绒西装的朋克。一位抵押贷款经纪人发现他70年代的旧朋克乐队在日本很受欢迎，于是决定暂时离开企业生活，重回巡演之路。
Act three. Ich... Bin... Ein... Mophead. A 34 year old man investigates who he was at nine years old, and learns a thing or two that he would just as soon not remember.
第三幕：我是……那个……拖把头。一位34岁的男子调查了自己9岁时是个什么样的人，并学到了一些他宁愿不去记住的事情。
Act four. Every day I forget something else. A ten year old explains memory with the help of novelist Nicholson Baker. Stay with us.
第四幕：我每天都在遗忘。一位10岁的小女孩在小说家尼科尔森·贝克的帮助下解释记忆。请继续收听。
Act One. Once More, With Feeling.
第一幕：再来一次，带着感情。
You may have heard of this series on Public Radio called Lost and Found Sound, which looks for old tapes to put on the radio. Well, one of the producers who works with that series, Valerie Velardi, knew a man named Jonathan Katz who loves old tapes. Loves them so much that he says that it just puts him in a good mood just to be around audio equipment. Naturally they got in touch. Katz is also a kind of minor celebrity in his own right. He did a TV series for a while about a cartoon psychiatrist called Dr. Katz.
你可能听说过公共广播电台的一档节目叫《失而复得之声》，专门搜寻老磁带并进行广播。该系列的一位制片人瓦莱丽·维拉尔迪认识一位热爱老磁带的男士，名叫乔纳森·卡茨。他热爱到什么程度呢？他说只要待在音响设备旁边，心情就会变好。顺理成章地，他们取得了联系。卡茨本人也是一位小有名气的人物。他曾出演过一部关于卡通精神病医生的电视剧，叫《卡茨医生》。
Anyway, Lost and Found Sound had Katz sit down with another one of the producers, a guy named Jay Allison, to play some of these old tapes of Katz's family. And after they did that, Katz then took his little journey into his childhood a step further.
总之，《失而复得之声》让卡茨与另一位制片人杰伊·阿利森坐在一起，播放了一些卡茨家庭的老磁带。在那之后，卡茨将他的童年之旅又向前推进了一步。
But I'm getting ahead of the story. Here's a few minutes first of him going through his old childhood tapes with Jay Allison.
但我说得有点超前了。先让他和杰伊·阿利森一起翻看童年磁带的几分钟片段。
K, I'm going to put the headphones on and do some serious time traveling. OK, hit play.
好了，我要戴上耳机开始一次严肃的时光旅行。OK，播放。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
I think even as a kid I knew how cheap tape was. If this was recorded today, there would be phones in the background. Somebody would be getting a fax. Somebody else would be checking their email. The TV would be on. It's kind of sad. Can't hear a kid breathe like this.
我想即使是个孩子，我也知道磁带有多便宜。如果这是今天录的，背景里肯定会有电话声。有人在收传真，有人在查邮件，电视开着。这真有点可悲。没法像这样听到一个孩子呼吸的声音。
Boy, am I wasting tape.
天哪，我真是浪费磁带。
Now it gives me great pleasure, on behalf of our entire congregation, to express our very good wishes to Mr. Sidney R. Katz and to Mrs. Katz upon the Bar Mitzvah this morning of their son Jonathan.
现在，我代表我们的整个会众，非常荣幸地向西德尼·R·卡茨先生和卡茨夫人致以美好的祝愿，祝贺他们的儿子乔纳森今天早上的受戒仪式。
To the ten thousands of the clans of Israel--
致以色列部落的万千族人——
That's me.
那是我的声音。
Verily I give you good doctrine--
我确实给予你们美好的教义——
I said "verily."
我说的是“确实”。
Bring us back to thee, oh Lord--
主啊，带我们回到你身边——
Lohd.
主。
Renew our days as of old. [SINGING IN HEBREW]
让我们如旧日般重焕新生。[用希伯来语歌唱]
I have a New York accent in Hebrew, which is pretty tough. Until I did my HBO special, this was the most money I ever got paid to perform live. Just going to move it ahead a little bit, just want to make sure-- whoa. Sorry about that.
我用希伯来语说话时竟然有纽约口音，这太难了。在做我的HBO特辑之前，这是我现场表演拿到的最高报酬。我往前快进一点，我想确保——哇。抱歉。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] We're desperate.
[听不清] 我们很绝望。
Doesn't sound like too much fun.
听起来不太有趣。
Nah. What are we having for dinner?
没。我们晚餐吃什么？
Eatin' food.
吃食物。
What kind of eatin' food?
什么样的食物？
The kind that people eat.
那种人们吃的食物。
OK. Let's hear this recording, OK?
OK。听听这段录音，好吗？
Oh, man. I have not changed one bit. That's what life is like at my house. We live, we videotape, and then we watch what we just did.
天哪，我一点都没变。这就是我家里的生活状态。我们生活，我们录像，然后回看我们刚才做的事。
And I have this obnoxious habit now with my daughter and her friends, both daughters. They can just be sitting around with a bunch of friends and I walk in with a tape recorder, and I go, "OK, talent show!" You know, which if you're 17, is pretty uncomfortable.
现在我和女儿还有她的朋友们在一起时有一个令人讨厌的习惯。她们可能和一群朋友坐在一起，我拿着录音机走进去说：“OK，才艺表演！”你知道，如果你17岁，这会让人非常尴尬。
Jonathan Katz now joins us from his home studio in Boston. Jonathan, how much taping do you do over the course of the week?
乔纳森·卡茨现在从波士顿的家庭工作室加入我们。乔纳森，你一周大概录多少时间的音？
Talent show! You know, I pretty much am always rolling. I'm recording something or listening to something. I'm surrounded by my past on audiotape.
才艺表演！你知道，我基本上一直在录。我总是在录音或者听东西。我的过去都被磁带包围着。
See, but how many hours of tape do you have there in your house?
但是，你家里到底有多少小时的磁带？
I would say-- you know, and it's very hard for me to give you an accurate estimate. But I would say 5,000 hours.
我想说——你知道，给我一个准确的估计很难。但我会说，5000个小时。
And how much of it have you actually gone back to?
你真正回头去听过多少？
Well, if I'm sitting in my office in my house writing something, rather than going downstairs and having a cup of coffee, I put on an old reel-to-reel tape and see what I find.
嗯，如果我坐在书房里写东西，而不是下楼去喝杯咖啡，我就会放一盘老磁带，看看我能发现什么。
Let's play one of the recent recordings you've made. Let me just get this queued up.
让我们播放一段你最近的录音。我来把它调出来。
Now when I see a picture hanging on the wall, it just reminds me of what could have been
现在当我看到墙上挂着一张照片，它只会让我想起曾经可能发生的一切。
Same with me. That's what I was going to say.
我也是。我正想说这个。
You know? And I still hope that maybe someday we can get together--
你知道吗？我仍然希望有一天我们能聚在一起——
Same with me.
我也是。
And make up for lost time.
弥补错失的时间。
Same with me.
我也是。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
And thinking of the ways that I could make you stay--
想着我可以让你留下的各种方式——
It's an odd choice of subject for a song to sing with your nine year old daughter.
作为一个和9岁女儿合唱的歌曲主题，这选择有点奇怪。
Yeah. Well, I mean, you could have "The Wheels on the Bus Go Round and Round" only so many times. You know?
是啊。我是说，《巴士轮子转呀转》那首歌就算再好听，也不能总是循环播放，你懂吗？
After digging up those old tapes and talking about them, you decided to get together with your sister Phyllis and return to your childhood home in Brooklyn. And it was it Sheepshead Bay?
在翻出那些旧磁带并谈论它们之后，你决定和你姐姐菲利斯一起回布鲁克林的童年故居。那是希普斯黑德湾吗？
Sheepshead Bay was where we lived. My earliest childhood memories were of our house in Sheepshead Bay.
我们住在希普斯黑德湾。我最早的童年记忆就是关于我们在希普斯黑德湾的房子的。
And how had it been since you'd been back?
自从你回去过之后，感觉如何？
I don't think I'd been there since the 1950s. It was a dirt road the last time I was there.
我想我从20世纪50年代起就没回去过。我上次去那儿时，那还是条土路。
No.
不是吧。
Yep.
真的。
A part of Brooklyn was a dirt road in the 1950s?
50年代的布鲁克林还有土路？
It's true. We lived on a dirt road.
这是真的。我们当时就住在一条土路上。
Why don't we turn right at Avenue 1 and go past your school to Ocean Avenue, OK?
我们为什么不在第一大道右转，经过你的学校到海洋大道呢，好吗？
Just explain the setup in the car when you went back to Brooklyn. Who was there?
解释一下你们回布鲁克林时车里的情况。都有谁？
I was driving with my sister Phyllis and an engineer.
我和我姐姐菲利斯还有一位工程师。
God. Marilyn Maybloom lived down whatever avenue it was.
天哪。玛丽琳·梅布卢姆就住在不管哪条大道上。
So you drove back to the old neighborhood, and you drive to a series of different houses that you had lived in. What was it like to knock on these doors of these different houses, trying to talk your way in?
所以你们开车回到了旧街区，去了你们住过的不同房子。敲开这些房子的门，试图进去看看，是什么感觉？
That was fun. And I think Phyllis has sort of a distorted view of my celebrity. That it was going to impress people, the fact that I used to be a cartoon.
那很有趣。我觉得菲利斯对我的名气有一种扭曲的看法。她觉得我曾经是个卡通人物，这会让人们印象深刻。
Right. You say to one person after another, I used to have this TV show. And not a one of them seems to have watched that show.
对。你对一个人接着一个人说，我曾经有一个电视节目。结果没一个人看过那个节目。
Who are you?
你是谁？
I'm Jonathan Katz. We used to live in this building. And I had a TV show called Dr. Katz remember a few years back? And I'm here with my sister Phyllis out of sentiment. And we lived on the fifth floor of this building.
我是乔纳森·卡茨。我们以前住在这栋楼里。我几年前做过一个叫《卡茨医生》的电视节目，还记得吗？我是和我姐姐菲利斯出于怀旧来的。我们以前住在这栋楼的五楼。
Well, if you'll excuse me, we're a little busy.
好吧，请原谅，我们有点忙。
I'm sorry. [INAUDIBLE] But we'll just go up. Thank you.
抱歉。[听不清] 不过我们还是上去吧。谢谢。
I guess the most amazing was this guy out of 88th Street. When he announced that he couldn't let us in because he's on an international call.
我想最让人吃惊的是88街的那个人。当他宣布不能让我们进去，因为他正在打国际长途时。
I know. It seems so archaic.
我知道。这看起来太古老了。
Like he was the first person to make contact with somebody from another country on the phone.
就像他是世界上第一个通过电话联系上外国的人一样。
May I help you?
有什么可以帮你的吗？
Oh, yes. Hi.
噢，是的。嗨。
I'm on an international call, so please be quick. What is this about?
我正在打国际长途，所以请快点。这是关于什么的？
We used to live here in 1966 and we wanted to see the apartment?
我们1966年住在这里，我们想看看公寓？
No. I'm speaking to my wife in Switzerland.
不行。我正在和我在瑞士的妻子通话。
If we were to come back, would it be possible?
如果我们要回来，有可能吗？
Yeah, possibly.
嗯，或许吧。
Sorry to bother you.
抱歉打扰了。
Everyone makes an international call. It's something to show off about, in his mind.
每个人都会打国际长途。在他看来，这是一种可以炫耀的东西。
You finally get into one of the houses. Was there a part of you that was surprised that-- like, in some way, that other people were living in the house?
你终于进到了其中一间房子里。有没有一部分的你对此感到惊讶——比如，居然有其他人在你曾经的家里生活？
Oh, I was shocked. I expected to see our furniture and oddly enough, my parents, who were worried sick. Where have we been?
噢，我被震惊了。我本以为会看到我们的家具，奇怪的是，还有我那担心得要命的父母。我们去哪儿了？
But of course, in a way. Because that's the way it looked the last time you were there.
但这当然是必然的。因为那是你上次在那儿时的样子。
Right. I sort of think of my homes, in Brooklyn especially, as the sets of sitcoms. You know, that they're frozen in time.
对。我有点把我的家，尤其是布鲁克林的家，当成了情景喜剧的布景。你知道，它们的时间是凝固的。
But instead we found this guy, Frank Mendez. And the reason he let us in wasn't his sentimentality. It's that it's on the market for $439,000. And it's a dump.
但相反，我们遇到了这个人，弗兰克·门德斯。他让我们进去的原因并非感伤。是因为房子正在以43.9万美元挂牌出售。而且这房子烂透了。
He was very hospitable. He showed us around. We were in the room where we-- Phillis and I shared a room until we moved to Manhattan.
他非常热情。他带我们到处看了看。我们在那个房间里——菲利斯和我在搬到曼哈顿之前共用的房间。
We used to live here.
我们以前住在这儿。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and see it.
[听不清] 看看它。
In 1949. Where's the bathroom you got locked in? It should be over here, eh?
1949年。你被锁在里面的那个厕所在哪？应该是在这儿吧，呃？
Yeah, when I was a kid, I got locked in the bathroom. They had to call the fire department.
是的，我小时候被锁在厕所里。他们不得不叫消防队。
There's your bathroom.
那是你的厕所。
She remembered it as cozy. I remembered it as claustrophobic.
她记得那很温馨。我记得那很幽闭恐惧。
Let's talk about how you got along with your sister on this trip. I want to play you a piece of tape.
聊聊你们在旅途中相处得如何。我想给你听一段磁带。
We just passed our old school. There's a house similar to this--
我们刚经过我们的老学校。这里有一所房子和那个很像——
Which school, though? Did I go there?
哪所学校？我去过吗？
130. But you wouldn't remember that either.
130号。但你也记不得那个了。
Do you want to go by there on the way back?
你回来的路上想经过那儿吗？
Yeah, maybe. We'll see.
是啊，或许吧。我们到时候看。
Let's head for our mutual memories first.
我们先去我们的共同记忆点吧。
But all these houses, there were beautiful private houses here, are not there.
但所有这些房子，这里曾有过漂亮的私人住宅，现在都不在了。
You know, I think if you dissect the dialogue, you can see that neither of us are really taking in what the other person is saying. And I'm pretty much making jokes, and whether or not she hears them, even, forget about gets them--
你知道，我认为如果你剖析这些对话，你会发现我们都没有真正听进去对方在说什么。我基本上一直在开玩笑，不管她有没有听进去，更别说听懂了——
Where's the theater, is it still here? Do you remember how much it used to cost?
剧院在哪，还在吗？你还记得以前要花多少钱吗？
Can you sound a little younger and less Jewish when you ask that question?
问这个问题的时候，你能不能声音听起来年轻一点，别那么犹太腔？
That's strange.
这真奇怪。
We're very competitive. And especially about our pasts. It's almost like revisionists. She wants her version of the past to be the one that's perceived as the truth.
我们竞争心很强。尤其是关于我们的过去。简直像历史修正主义者。她希望她的过去版本是被视为真相的那一个。
What's the difference between your sister's version of the past and your version of the past?
你和你姐姐的过去版本有什么区别？
I believe that there was a second World War. No. I think that her version-- the big difference was that she and I got along when we kids.
我相信有第二次世界大战。不。我想她的版本——最大的区别在于她认为我们小时候关系很好。
She thinks that you got along?
她觉得你们关系很好？
Yeah. She thinks that we were a happier family than I think we were.
是啊。她觉得我们是一个比我认为的更幸福的家庭。
I wonder if just that she was happier.
我在想是不是因为她当时更幸福。
That's possible. It's a nice interpretation.
有可能。这是一个不错的解读。
I expected to find some evidence of a happy childhood. When in fact I couldn't really get along with my sister.
我本想寻找幸福童年的证据。而事实上，我和我姐姐根本相处不来。
You know what's so strange about this trip that you took back to the neighborhood, is you're really dealing with the most potent psychological material possible. You're going back to the place where you grew up. You haven't been there in decades. You'd think it would bring back a flood of memories and feelings, and nothing happens.
你知道，你这次重回旧街区的旅行最奇怪的地方在于，你是在处理最具潜在心理影响的素材。你回到了你成长的地方。你几十年没去过那里了。你本以为这会唤起如潮水般的记忆和感受，结果什么都没发生。
It is odd. Well, you know, it's a little bit like this TV show that I made. And I'm not trying to change the subject. I did a TV show recently about-- it was called Alpha Force. And the premise was, it was six guys living in a bunker underneath Utah, all specialists in some field. I was an electronics specialist. And we were set up by the government to do covert operations in foreign countries.
确实很奇怪。嗯，你知道，这有点像我做的那个电视节目。我不是想转移话题。我最近做了一个节目，叫《阿尔法力量》。前提是六个家伙住在一起，在犹他州的一个地堡里，每个人都是某个领域的专家。我是电子专家。我们由政府安置，在国外执行秘密行动。
But no one called. We're just in the bunker. No one's calling. So I suggested we start a book club. And that's kind of where we are now, at this piece.
但没人打电话。我们只是待在地堡里。没人打来。所以我建议我们成立一个读书俱乐部。这就是我们现在在这个片段里的状态。
You didn't get what you wanted out of your trip back home.
你在回家的旅行中没有得到你想要的。
No.
没有。
What did you want? You said earlier, a part of what you were looking for was just some sign about whether things were happy when you were a kid. What would you have heard on these tapes, or seen in the old neighborhood, that would have given you it?
你想要什么？你刚才说过，你寻找的一部分原因只是为了找个迹象，看看你小时候是否真的幸福。如果是这些磁带里听到的，或者是旧街区里看到的，什么能给你这个答案呢？
You know, if I had been able to rip away at the wallpaper in that house, and see the words written by me-- "Sweet God, life is so good." I mean, I look at my 18 year old daughter, and I see how unbelievably alive and happy she is. And I guess that's the feeling that I'm looking for.
你知道，如果我能撕掉那房子的壁纸，看到我自己写的字——“亲爱的上帝，生活如此美好。”我是说，我看着我18岁的女儿，看到她是多么令人难以置信地充满活力和快乐。我想那可能就是我正在寻找的感觉。
You mean, when you listen back through these tapes?
你是说当你回头听这些磁带的时候？
Yeah. That I'm looking for evidence that I, too used to be that happy and alive. You know, looking at a black and white photograph of that house with my father and my mother, and me and my cousins and my sister sitting on the steps might be more potent than actually sitting on those steps.
是的。我是在寻找证据，证明我也曾那样快乐和充满活力。你知道，看着那张我和父母、我和堂兄弟姐妹还有姐姐坐在台阶上的黑白照片，可能比实际坐在那些台阶上更有力量。
Comedian Jonathan Katz.
喜剧演员乔纳森·卡茨。
Act Two. Punk In a Grey Flannel Suit.
第二幕：身穿灰色法兰绒西装的朋克。
David Philp is the president of a mortgage brokerage firm in Beverly Hills. As you might imagine, in Beverly Hills, they handle rather large mortgages. He dresses neatly in beautiful clothes. He has clean-cut hair.
戴维·菲尔普是比弗利山庄一家抵押贷款经纪公司的总裁。正如你所想的，在比弗利山庄，他们处理的是相当大的抵押贷款。他穿着整齐，服装考究。发型一丝不苟。
But in the 1970s, in his native England, he was in a punk band called the Automatics, which was never really a big commercial success, but known and respected in the history of the punk movement there by people who care about these kinds of things. And last year, through an odd set of connections, he ended up revisiting his teenage years for the first time by going back on tour in a version of his band in Japan. Here is how something like that happens.
但在20世纪70年代，在他家乡英国，他是一个叫“自动装置”的朋克乐队成员，这支乐队在商业上从未取得过巨大成功，但在那里朋克运动的历史中，被那些关心这类事情的人所熟知和尊重。而去年，通过一系列奇妙的人脉，他终于通过在日本重回他当年的乐队巡演，第一次重温了他的少年时代。这就是这种事发生的过程。
I mentioned it to a client. And I said, well, I played in a punk group when I was a kid. And he said, oh, really? And he's interested. And then the next day, he sent me a copy of an eBay auction, and said, is this you?
我向一位客户提到过。我说，好吧，我小时候在一个朋克乐队演奏。他说，哦，真的吗？他很感兴趣。第二天，他发给我一份eBay拍卖的链接，说，这是你吗？
It was. And I watched this auction. I watched the price shoot through the roof. And then I began to realize, wait a minute! I'm collectible.
确实是我。我看着这场拍卖。我看着价格直线上升。然后我开始意识到，等一下！我很有收藏价值。
Let's get down to brass tacks here. How much were you guys?
让我们开门见山吧。你们卖了多少钱？
I think that one actually went at $48. I particularly liked looking at all those sort of other groups that were going at $0.25. You know, music business offerings along punk lines that I thought, what a load of nonsense, at the time. And it was good to see that their records weren't valued years later. I mean, it was--
我觉得那一盘成交价是48美元。我特别喜欢看其他那些成交价只有0.25美元的音乐组合。你知道，当时那些朋克路线的音乐产品，我当时觉得，那真是胡扯。很高兴看到多年后他们的唱片并不值钱。我是说，这——
Wow. That history came out on the right side.
哇。历史站在了正确的一边。
Yes. That there is a sort of Darwinism in record-collecting.
是的。唱片收藏界也存在一种达尔文主义。
What happened next?
接下来发生了什么？
I went to go see Ricky, the drummer. And Ricky collected everything. And he very kindly lent me these two scrapbooks. So I took pictures and things out of there. I just had a friend put it up on a website. And then I got an email from Fifi in Japan, saying, oh, I play in a Japanese punk rock band, and--
我去找了鼓手瑞奇。瑞奇什么都收集。他非常慷慨地把这两本剪贴簿借给了我。所以我把里面的照片之类的东西拿出来。我让一个朋友把这些放到了网站上。然后我收到了来自日本菲菲的一封邮件，说，哦，我在一个日本朋克摇滚乐队演奏，你的唱片改变了我的人生。
Fifi's a name of a person?
菲菲是一个人的名字？
Yes. --and your record changed my life.
是的。——你的唱片改变了我的人生。
Wow.
哇。
And he found out through the website that there was an unreleased album. So he asked if he put me in touch with Toshio Iijima of Base Records. We struck up a deal. And then they said, well, would you come over here and play some gigs to, you know, promote?
他通过网站发现有一张未发行的专辑。所以他问如果他联系基地唱片公司的Toshio Iijima，他可以吗。我们谈成了交易。然后他们说，好吧，你愿不愿意过来做几场演出，你知道，进行推广？
So you go to tour. How old are you at that point?
所以你去巡演。那时候你多大？
45.
45岁。
A little bit of grey hair coming in, perhaps?
也许有点白头发了？
A little bit of grey hair coming in. And I really wasn't sure whether I'd still be able to do it. Because I hadn't played those songs in 22 years. You know? Not in my shower. Not to anyone. I mean, prior to being married-- I mean, I remember dating women for a year who never knew that I played. Had ever played.
有点白头发了。我真的不确定我还能不能做到。因为我已经有22年没弹过那些歌了。你知道吗？连在浴室里都没弹过。没给任何人弹过。我是说，结婚前——我记得和女性约会了一年，她们都不知道我玩过乐队。从来没玩过。
It wouldn't even come up?
甚至提都没提过？
Wouldn't come up, really. I mean, I'd have a guitar hanging around, but lots of other guys did, too.
没提过，真的。我是说，我家里一直有把吉他，但很多其他男人也有。
Would you ever pick up the guitar and play for yourself?
你有没有试过拿起吉他为自己弹奏？
Yes. I wrote a lot of songs for my dog during this period.
有。这段时间我为我的狗写了很多歌。
Really? Some of the titles would be--
真的？有些歌名会是——
"We're Going to the Park" was a big favorite.
《我们要去公园》是最受欢迎的。
To be followed by that hit, "Who's A Good Boy?"
随后是那首热门曲目，《谁是个乖狗狗？》
"Oh, What A Good Boy," is actually--
《噢，多乖的狗狗》，其实是——
It is?
真的吗？
[PANTS] What a, what a good boy!
[喘气声] 多乖，多乖的狗狗！
So we went over there October the sixth. I took my wife. Which possibly was a miscalculation, but-- No, it was a good thing to take my wife, because--
所以我们在10月6日去了那里。我带上了我妻子。这可能是一个失误，但——不，带上我妻子是件好事，因为——
You were approached by dozens of teenage girls?
你被几十个十几岁的女孩搭讪了？
I was getting stopped on the street.
我走在街上被人拦住。
So what happened the first night you went onstage?
你第一晚登台时发生了什么？
Well, there was just the announcement, the light, and sort of a moment's silence, which lasted forever. And then sort of-- out at the back I heard the opening riff of "When the Tanks Roll Over Poland." And there was just this whole ignition of energy from the club, in front. And all these kids just started going mad. And it just clicked right in.
嗯，主持人刚宣布完，灯光亮起，出现了一阵沉默，仿佛持续了很久。然后——在后面我听到了《坦克碾过波兰时》的开场连复段。台下的俱乐部瞬间爆发出了巨大的能量。孩子们都疯了。这感觉一下子就对上了。
It felt like I was in an Automatics cover band or something like that. Because it was so long ago, I didn't feel that association as the writer. Because I wrote the material and all that. I didn't have that association as the writer anymore.
感觉就像我在一个翻唱“自动装置”乐队的乐队里演奏一样。因为那已经是好久以前的事了，我不再有那种作为创作者的关联感。虽然那些歌是我写的。我不再有那种关联感了。
See, but I would wonder, if as you sing the songs, the conviction of the writing returns to you, and you remember all the feelings of it. Did that happen?
看，但我很好奇，当你演唱这些歌曲时，创作时的信念有没有回到你身上，你是否记起了当时所有的感受？那发生了吗？
There's a muscle memory that was there. You know, the movements are all locked in the lyrics and the beat and the parts. And as I played them, they all started to come out, and it was just like being a marionette or something. Here you punch the air. There you sort of bring it, remind the drummer to come down. And there you point at the guitarist for the solo.
有一种肌肉记忆就在那里。你知道，动作都锁在歌词、节奏和伴奏里了。当我弹奏它们时，一切都自然而然地出来了，就像个提线木偶一样。在这里你要挥动空气，那里你要带一下节奏提醒鼓手，那里你要指向吉他手让他独奏。
Had you forgotten the thrill of being onstage?
你有没有忘记过在舞台上的那种快感？
Yes. I'd forgotten what it was to have the audience right there.
是的。我忘记了那种观众就在台下的感觉。
Before this, had you ever performed a punk show sober?
在此之前，你有过清醒地表演朋克秀吗？
Never. Well, unless I was taking the antibiotics.
从来没有。除非我在服用抗生素。
So much information contained in such a brief sentence.
如此简短的一句话里包含了太多的信息。
No, it actually was one of the great paradoxes, really, I suppose. That it was great to do it sober.
不，这实际上是一个伟大的悖论，我想。清醒着表演感觉真的很棒。
Were there moments onstage where you felt your age? where you just thought, oh--
在舞台上有过感觉自己老了的时候吗？你有没有想过，噢——
Towards the end, you really feel yourself. Because it's like a sauna up there. I mean, there's so much energy going around. And it's louder than bombs.
快结束的时候，你真的能感觉到自己的岁数。因为台上有桑拿般的热度。我是说，到处都是能量。而且声音大得像炸弹一样。
So your wife had never seen you do this before. There must've been a part of you which felt pleased that she could see it?
你妻子以前从没见过你这样表演。你心里一定有一部分很高兴她能看到吧？
Yes. I felt kind of like I'd become this other person. And when I was over there, my life over here seemed to have a sort of almost dreamlike substance. And then of course as soon as I go back, the events in October, in Japan, just began to assume that mantle of dream.
是的。我觉得自己好像变成了另一个人。当我在那边时，我在这里的生活似乎带有一种近乎梦幻的实质。当然，当我一回去，10月份在日本发生的那些事情，又开始带上梦幻的色彩了。
I did three shows. Two in Tokyo and one in Kyoto.
我做了三场演出。东京两场，京都一场。
And all three, just great.
三场都太棒了。
All three sold out. In Kyoto, we set a club record for the largest attendance ever. It was so packed, we couldn't actually get offstage. The only way out was over. I had to sling myself over the audience, and they carried me on their hands back through the crowd, and gently deposited me at the stage door.
三场全部售罄。在京都，我们创下了俱乐部史上最高的上座率。现场太挤了，我们根本没法走下台。唯一的出路是在观众头上。我不得不把自己扔向人群，他们用手托着我穿过人群，温柔地把我放到了后台出口。
So this is your last gig? That was your last gig?
所以这是你的最后一场演出？那是你的最后一场？
Yes.
是的。
And it ended with the entire audience lifting you up, and passing you bodily out, and gently depositing you out of the club?
它以全体观众把你托起来，把你传出去，并温柔地把你送到俱乐部外面结束？
Well, not out of the club, but to the stage door, yes. It was amazing.
嗯，不是送出俱乐部，而是送到后台出口，是的。这太神奇了。
I don't think I've ever really been lifted by a mob of teenagers and people in their 20s. What exactly is that like?
我想我从没被一群青少年和20多岁的人托起来过。那到底是什么感觉？
Well, in Kyoto, I felt pretty good about it. I'm not sure how I would have felt about it in London in 1977, where the scene was incredibly violent. Whenever you played, you were just as likely to get beaten up as you were to get paid.
嗯，在京都，我感觉很好。我不知道如果这事发生在1977年的伦敦我会怎么想，那里的现场极其暴力。无论你什么时候演出，被打一顿的可能性和拿到演出费的可能性一样大。
Describe what it was like to come back after the tour.
描述一下巡演后回来的感觉。
It was hard for me to get motivated again to do my business after the tour.
巡演后，我很难再有动力去经营我的业务。
It just wasn't as thrilling as being on the a in front of cheering--
那远没有在台上对着欢呼的人群——
Well, not many things are. And it was a bit like, sort of, my dad's generation. After growing up as a kid, being fired on in World War II and all that kind of stuff. It was kind of hard getting it up for working in the shipping industry again.
嗯，很少有事情能比得上那个。这有点像我父亲那一代。从小在二战中被枪林弹雨洗礼，经历那些事。再让他们回到航运业工作是很难提起劲来的。
Shortly after I got back, Steve Lillywhite was in town.
我回来不久，史蒂夫·利利怀特就在城里。
And that is?
那是谁？
He was the original producer. And he was also my roommate at the time that all the Automatics stuff was going on. And now he's incredibly successful. He does, like, U2, Dave Matthews, and all that stuff.
他是最初的制片人。也是“自动装置”乐队活跃时期我的室友。现在他非常成功。他做像U2、戴夫·马修斯等人的唱片。
And anyway, he was in town, and he had some time. And so we hung out together for a couple of days. And Hunter was off. Hunter, my wife.
总之，他在城里，而且有空。我们就在一起待了两天。亨特没在。亨特是我妻子。
So we got to hang out. And we talked a little about the old days. And he told me, Big Paul from Specs does catering. And Nigel from the Members is in Australia now. And Walter from the Heartbreakers, he's a stockbroker in Manhattan.
我们聚在一起，聊了聊过去的日子。他告诉我，大保罗在做餐饮，成员乐队的奈杰尔现在在澳大利亚，心碎乐队的沃尔特成了曼哈顿的证券经纪人。
So I think I got to see, we don't get what we deserve. We get what we get. And we have to be OK with that.
所以我想我明白了，我们得到的并不是我们应得的。我们得到的就是我们所得到的。我们必须学会接受。
David Philp, lead singer of the Automatics. Though he has not quit his day job, he's been recording in the studio lately, and hopes to tour Germany in the fall.
“自动装置”乐队主唱戴维·菲尔普。虽然他没有辞去日常工作，但最近一直在录音室录音，并希望秋天去德国巡演。
Why is it that the Axis powers are the ones who are going for this music right now? What is that about?
为什么现在的轴心国国家对这种音乐趋之若鹜？那是关于什么的？
Coming up, a famous novelist and actress from the TV show Buffy the Vampire Slayer. The impossibility of time and memory and a babysitter. It's action, action, action, believe me, in just one minute, from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一位著名小说家和电视剧《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》中的演员。关于时间、记忆和保姆的不可能性。这就是动作，动作，动作，相信我，一分钟后，我们的节目从国际公共广播电台继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Return to Childhood. Stories of people revisiting the past, what they find there, what they do not find there.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目里，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“重返童年”。人们重温过去的故事，他们发现了什么，又没有发现什么。
We have arrived at act three of our show. And this act is the story of how one of the producers of this program made a decision to return to his childhood. Alex Blumberg went searching for somebody named Susan Jordan, who he and his sister Kate and their parents knew for about a year when he was growing up in Cincinnati.
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。这一幕的故事是本节目的制片人之一如何决定回归他的童年。亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格去寻找一个叫苏珊·乔丹的人，当他在辛辛那提成长时，他和他的姐姐凯特以及他们的父母认识了她大约一年。
These are the things that I remember about Susan Jordan. Me and her sitting in the back room, telling her about the day camp I went to that summer. I can't get myself to shut up. "And they had alligators, and snakes," I can hear myself telling her. "And this one time, this one alligator got out, and the counselor had to catch it." And on and on, like that.
这就是我关于苏珊·乔丹的记忆。我和她坐在后屋，告诉她我那天夏天参加的日营。我没法让自己停下来。“他们有鳄鱼，还有蛇，”我能听到自己告诉她，“有一次，一只鳄鱼跑出来了，管理员不得不抓住它。”就这样没完没了地说。
Me and Susan flipping through one of those Time Life books. Rock and Roll Through the Decades: The Sixties. She has long, brown hair. She's incredibly skinny. It's 1975. She's wearing bell bottom Levis, a faded jean jacket. She points to a picture of a bloated man in a powder blue rhinestone jumpsuit sitting cross-legged on a stage before a crowd of crying women. "That's my favorite picture of Elvis," she says. This information seems somehow personal and important.
我和苏珊翻看着其中一本《时代生活》的图书：《摇滚乐的几十年：六十年代》。她留着长长的棕色头发。她瘦得惊人。那是1975年。她穿着喇叭口的李维斯牛仔裤，一件褪色的牛仔夹克。她指着一张照片，照片上一个臃肿的男人穿着粉蓝色的莱茵石连身裤，盘腿坐在舞台上，面前是一群哭泣的女人。“那是关于猫王，我最喜欢的一张照片，”她说。这个信息似乎在某种程度上非常私密且重要。
Me and Susan riding in her car. I'm going through this phase where I'm trying to notice things. So when we pull up to a stoplight, I start trying to notice the guy on the motorcycle next to us. He apparently doesn't want to be noticed, especially by a peculiar nine year old staring at him through the passenger window. "What are you looking at?" he sneers. I turn around fast and face the dashboard.
我和苏珊坐着她的车。我正处于一个试图观察事物的阶段。所以当我们停在红灯前，我开始试图观察旁边摩托车上的那个人。他显然不想被注意，尤其是不想被一个奇特的9岁男孩通过副驾驶车窗盯着看。“你在看什么？”他冷笑着说。我迅速转过身面对仪表盘。
"Did he say something to you?" Susan asks. "What did he say to you?"
“他跟你说了什么吗？”苏珊问。“他说了什么？”
"Nothing. He didn't say anything. It's fine. Look! Green light!"
“没什么。他什么也没说。没事。看！绿灯了！”
"Tell me what he said. What did he say to you?"
“告诉我他说了什么。他跟你说了什么？”
I stay silent. I know if I tell her what he said, she'll get out of the car and try to kick his ass. Which scares me, but comforts me, too.
我保持沉默。我知道如果我告诉她他说了什么，她会下车试图踢他的屁股。这让我感到害怕，但也让我感到慰藉。
Susan Jordan was our babysitter. She watched my sister and me every day after school for a couple hours until our parents got home from work. We didn't know any adults like her and we loved her. The summer before I started fifth grade, after being with us for a year, Susan got another job.
苏珊·乔丹是我们的保姆。她每天放学后负责照顾我和我姐姐几个小时，直到我们父母下班回来。我们不认识像她这样的大人，我们很爱她。就在我上五年级前的那个夏天，和我们相处了一年后，苏珊找了另一份工作。
The last time I saw her was Christmas Eve 1982. I'm 16, a cashier Thriftway Foods, a supermarket in Cincinnati, where I lived. The place is packed. All 25 registers are going. People are lined up halfway to the back of the store. I look up, and there's Susan Jordan.
我最后一次见到她是在1982年的平安夜。我16岁，在辛辛那提的一家叫Thriftway Foods的超市做收银员。店里挤满了人。所有25个收银台都在运作。人们排成的队伍延伸到了商店后半段。我抬头一看，是苏珊·乔丹。
She smiles. We talk. She doesn't have many items, so I check them through as slowly as I possibly can. I can't recall one thing we say to each other, although I remember being distinctly disappointed to hear that she's married. She hands me some kind of business card, her husband's, probably, something having to do with the building of redwood decks. She seems happy.
她微笑了。我们谈话。她没买多少东西，所以我尽量极其缓慢地把它们扫码结账。我记不清我们谈论的一件事，尽管我记得听到她结婚了时明显感到失望。她递给我一张某种名片，可能是她丈夫的，大概是关于建造红杉木甲板之类的业务。她看起来很幸福。
Meanwhile there's a line of last-minute Christmas shoppers mounting behind her. I tell her to hold on, I'll try to get my break, we can catch up. She says great, and steps aside. I keep signaling to my manager, but there's no one to relieve me. Five, ten, fifteen minutes pass. I keep glancing behind at Susan, making apologetic gestures. I can still remember her standing there, holding her one bag of groceries, smiling back at me.
同时，她身后排起了最后时刻买圣诞用品的购物者队伍。我告诉她等一下，我会试着轮休，我们可以叙叙旧。她说太好了，走到了一边。我不断示意经理，但没有人能替我。五分钟、十分钟、十五分钟过去了。我不断回头看苏珊，做着道歉的手势。我至今还能想起她站在那里，手里拿着一袋杂货，对我微笑着的样子。
Finally she taps me on the shoulder. "I have to go," she says. "But I come in here all the time. I'm sure I'll see you around."
最后，她拍了拍我的肩膀。“我得走了，”她说，“但我经常来这儿。我相信我们还会再见的。”
I worked at Thriftway for two more years. I never saw Susan Jordan again.
我在Thriftway又工作了两年。我再也没见过苏珊·乔丹。
It drives me crazy that I never saw her again. If I hadn't run into her at the store, I don't think I'd care. But somehow, having her play what, to me, seemed like a huge role in my life when I was a kid, and then getting just a taste of what it would be like to talk with her as a peer-- I've never forgotten that moment.
我没能再见到她这件事快把我逼疯了。如果我没在商店遇到她，我可能根本不在乎。但不知何故，她在童年时期扮演了一个对我而言似乎很重要的角色，而当我第一次尝到作为同龄人与她交谈的滋味后——我从来没有忘记那一刻。
I know it's ridiculous. But after years of thinking about her, imagining what she's up to, wondering if she ever thinks about me, I decide to find her.
我知道这很可笑。但在思考她多年之后，想象她的近况，想知道她是否偶尔会想起我，我决定找到她。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
[DIALING]
[拨号中]
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
I start with my only lead. The one former employer of hers that I know.
我从我唯一的线索开始。我知道的她唯一的前雇主。
Hi mom,
妈，
Hi Alex.
嗨，亚历克斯。
Do you want to know why I'm calling?
你想知道我为什么打电话吗？
I do, I do.
想啊，想啊。
You remember Susan Jordan, right?
你记得苏珊·乔丹，对吧？
Susan Jordan. Yes, it's ringing a bell, but I can't place it.
苏珊·乔丹。是的，名字听着耳熟，但我记不起来了。
She was our babysitter?
她是我们的保姆？
Oh. OK. Chicken Legs and Mophead.
噢。OK。鸡腿和拖把头。
One of the many ideas that Susan introduced to our household was the concept of the nickname. I think that's all I want to say about Chicken Legs and Mophead.
苏珊引入我们家庭的众多概念之一就是绰号。我想关于“鸡腿”和“拖把头”我只想说这么多。
I'd gone to my mother to fill in gaps in my memory of Susan, but she didn't remember much more than I did.
我找我妈是为了填补我对苏珊的记忆空白，但她记得的并不比我多。
She was a babysitter that really had more of a relationship with you two than she did with us. She seemed to have a very meaningful relationship with you. Almost the kind of relationship you might have another adult. That was about the extent of it. And she never stayed around when I came home. She was out of there.
她是一个保姆，比起我们，她和你们俩的关系更亲近。她似乎和你们有一种非常有意义的关系。几乎就像你可能和另一个成年人拥有的那种关系。这就是全部了。她在我回家时从不逗留。她总是直接走了。
What talking to my mom did do was make me look at my childhood memories from an adult perspective. Like for example, what I remembered about her living situation.
和妈妈的谈话确实让我从成年人的角度去审视我的童年记忆。比如，关于她的居住情况的记忆。
I didn't get the impression that she was close to her family. I got the impression that she was very much out on her own very young. I think she must have been in the process of breaking with her own parents during that time.
我不觉得她和她的家人很亲近。我的印象是她很早就独立了。我想那段时间她一定处于和自己父母决裂的过程中。
That's, yeah. See, my memory is that like, she was in high school, right? She went to Withrow. But I also remember her living on her-- for some reason I remember her own house. And the reason I thought she lived by herself was we went to her house or her boyfriend's-- we had to go pick something up somewhere, and we were in her car. This big blue Duster, I think it was. And her boyfriend was there. And her boyfriend had let the cats out, and they were gone. And she was furious. And then I got in the car, and then she slammed the door, and I think we peeled out. And he was sort of standing there and trying to reason with her, and we were out of there.
那是，是的。看，我的记忆是她当时在上高中，对吧？她去了威瑟罗中学。但我还记得她独自生活——不知为什么，我记得她有自己的房子。我以为她自己住的原因是我们去过她家或者是她男友的——我们得去某个地方拿东西，我们在她的车里。那是一辆大蓝色达斯特，我想是那样。她男朋友也在。她男朋友把猫放出去了，结果猫丢了。她当时暴跳如雷。我上了车，她猛地关上门，我想我们飞驰而去。他站在那儿试图跟她讲理，而我们离开了。
Well, what did you think?
那么你怎么看？
It made me-- I think I felt sad for her. I remember thinking-- and this is sort of in retrospect. But I think I had some sort of inkling of this idea at the time, and I'm just sort of now realizing it. But I think-- I remember thinking that he was one of the few people that she had in her life, and she couldn't even really depend on him.
这让我——我想我当时为她感到难过。我记得当时在想——这是事后追忆了。但我认为我当时就有某种潜意识的想法，而我现在才意识到。但是我认为——我记得我当时觉得他是她生命中为数不多的人之一，而她甚至不能真正依赖他。
Yeah, you were probably right. She was a struggler. And you may have been, at that point, at that moment, her only friend. You know?
是的，你可能说对了。她是个在挣扎的人。而那一刻，你可能就是她唯一的朋友。你知道吗？
My mom didn't have any idea where I could find Susan, which made things difficult. Because A, Susan Jordan is a very common name, and B, it's probably not her name anymore. I called the county court records department to find all the Susan Jordans married in Cincinnati. My mom asked a friend who worked for the city to search all the Cincinnati birth records. I contacted high school alumni associations. I asked friends at high-powered newspapers to run background checks.
我妈根本不知道去哪能找到苏珊，这让事情变得很困难。因为第一，苏珊·乔丹是一个非常常见的名字，第二，这很可能已经不是她的名字了。我打电话给县法院记录部门查找所有在辛辛那提结婚的苏珊·乔丹。我妈让我一个在市政府工作的朋友搜索了所有辛辛那提的出生记录。我联系了高中校友会。我让在高级报社工作的朋友进行了背景调查。
Finally, there was one former Susan Jordan who stood out. She seemed the right age. She was married, living in a Cincinnati suburb. She had a couple of kids. Her husband was a lawyer. I got her number from information.
最后，有一个前苏珊·乔丹引起了我的注意。她年龄似乎正好。她结了婚，住在一个辛辛那提郊区。她有两个孩子。她丈夫是名律师。我通过查询得到了她的号码。
And it wasn't until I sat down to call her that it hit me. A phone call from someone you babysat 20 years ago might not be a welcome surprise, but in fact strange and creepy. Here I am practicing sounding benign.
直到我坐下来给她打电话，我才意识到。一个20年前当过你保姆的人打来的电话可能不是什么惊喜，事实上反倒显得奇怪和诡异。我在这儿练习着让声音听起来温和一点。
One, two, one, two. Susan. Is this Susan Jordan? Is this Susan Jordan? Oh god, oh god.
一，二，一，二。苏珊。是苏珊·乔丹吗？是苏珊·乔丹吗？噢上帝，噢上帝。
Finally I made the call.
终于我拨出了电话。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello?
你好？
Hello. Hi. Is this Susan?
你好。嗨。是苏珊吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Hi. My name is Alex Blumberg and I'm calling from a radio program called This American Life. And this is probably a very strange phone call to receive. But I was wondering, first of all, do you remember me?
嗨。我是亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格，我打电话来是来自一个叫《美国生活》的广播节目。这可能是一个非常奇怪的电话。但我想问问，首先，你还记得我吗？
No.
不记得。
It turns out there are a lot of Susan Jordans who don't remember me. A lot. One guy even called his ex-wife, a former Susan Jordan, and then called me back to tell me she'd never heard of me. I was getting nowhere by myself.
事实证明有很多叫苏珊·乔丹的人都不记得我。很多。甚至有一个人打电话问了他前妻——一个叫苏珊·乔丹的人，然后回电告诉我她从来没听说过我。我一个人什么进展都没有。
So I contacted a professional. One Irving Botwinick, a certified New York City private investigator. Three days after putting him on the case, I got a message saying he'd found her. I called him back.
所以我联系了一位专业人士。欧文·波特威尼克，一位持有执照的纽约私人侦探。在他接手案件三天后，我收到消息说他找到她了。我给他打了回去。
I called her this morning early. Roughly around 7:30. I said, good morning. I'd like to introduce myself. I said my name is so-and-so, and I'm a licensed private investigator in New York, and I'm looking for someone that used to live in Cincinnati, and went to a particular school there, and her name at the time was Susan Jordan. And she said, that's me. And I said, OK. And I said, do you know anybody named Alex Blumberg. And right away she, yeah. I babysat for him. And the interesting part about the whole thing is she definitely likes you, remembers you, and she's going to call you.
我今天一早给她打了电话。大约在7:30左右。我说，早上好。我想自我介绍一下。我说我叫某某，我是纽约的一名持照私人侦探，我正在寻找一个过去住在辛辛那提，当时上过某所学校，名字叫苏珊·乔丹的人。她说，那是我。我说，OK。我说，你认识一个叫亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格的人吗。她立刻就说，嗯，我给他当过保姆。整个事情最有趣的部分是，她真的很喜欢你，记得你，而且她会给你打电话。
Hello, is this Susan?
你好，是苏珊吗？
Yeah.
是的。
This is Alex Blumberg.
我是亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格。
Hi, Alex. How are you doing?
嗨，亚历克斯。你好吗？
I'm doing OK. How are you?
我很好。你呢？
Fine. Did you get my email?
挺好的。你收到我的邮件了吗？
I got your email, yeah.
我收到你的邮件了，是的。
Oh, OK.
噢，OK。
Susan and I talked for over three hours on the phone, catching up, comparing notes. She asked about my sister, and kids that used to live on the street, and our old family dog. It was amazing how much she remembered and how much we remembered in common. Even small incidents like the time that we were stopped at the traffic light and I stared too long at the guy on the motorcycle.
苏珊和我在电话里聊了三个多小时，交流近况，互通消息。她问起了我姐姐，还有住在那条街上的孩子们，以及我们以前的家犬。她记得那么多事情，我们共同拥有的记忆居然有那么多，这真令人吃惊。甚至连像我们在红灯前被堵住，我盯着摩托车上的那个人看了太久那种小细节，她都记得。
I think I remember that. Was it on Erie Avenue?
我想我记得那个。是在伊利大道吗？
Probably, probably. And you said, did he say something you? And I said, no, he didn't say anything to me. And you said, he said something to you, didn't he? And you were about to get out of the car and kick that guy's ass. I'm sure.
应该是，应该是。你当时说，他跟你说了什么吗？我说，没，他没对我说话。你说，他肯定对你说了什么，对吧？然后你差点下车去踢那个家伙的屁股。我敢肯定。
I think I can remember your face. I think you were sitting very still with your hands in your lap. Were you afraid?
我想我能记得你的脸。我想你当时坐得一动不动，双手放在膝盖上。你当时害怕吗？
I was terrified, yeah. I didn't know that he would notice, exactly.
我当时吓坏了，是的。我不知道他会注意到，真的。
Well, don't worry I would have taken him out. I had no fear. I'm telling you.
嗯，别担心，我会干掉他的。我当时毫无畏惧。我跟你说。
Do you remember a time-- it was like maybe six or seven or eight years after you babysat us. And I was working--
你记得有一次吗——那大概是你当完我们保姆六、七、八年后。那时我在工作——
The grocery store? Yeah, I remember. In Norwood, right?
那个杂货店？是的，我记得。在诺伍德，对吧？
In Norwood, right, at the Thriftway.
在诺伍德，对吧，在Thriftway。
Yeah. I remember. I guess you-- were you bagging my groceries, but I didn't recognize you?
是的。我记得。我猜你——你是当时在帮我装杂货，但我没认出你？
I don't--
我不——
And then you told me who you were, and then I did.
然后你告诉了我你是谁，然后我就认出来了。
Right. Right. I think you said "Mophead."
对。对。我想你当时叫了“拖把头”。
Oh my god. I did warp you. Do people still call you that?
噢，天哪。我确实把你带歪了。还有人那样叫你吗？
No.
没了。
Susan got married when she was still in college and went to work for the phone company as a repair person. She spent the next 20 years or so hanging from a telephone pole, she said. She hated it, but the money was good. Around the time her first marriage ended, she finally got up the courage to quit and find work using her degree. She now teaches at a special school for mentally ill children. She lives in Florida with her second husband and she seems happy.
苏珊在大学还没毕业时就结婚了，去电话公司做了维修工。她说她接下来的20年左右都在电线杆上挂着。她讨厌那工作，但钱多。在第一次婚姻结束前后，她终于鼓起勇气辞职，并用她的学位找到了工作。她现在在一所专门为精神疾病儿童设立的学校教书。她和第二任丈夫住在佛罗里达，看起来很幸福。
Of course, when you dive back into the past like this, you find how partial and incomplete your memory is. First there are the facts you get wrong. Turns out Susan had been a college freshman when she babysat us, not in high school like I thought. My sister remembered she'd ridden a motorcycle. Also not true. And the guy who she got in a fight with over the cats, who in my mind was her hairy '70s boyfriend, turned out to be her roommate's boyfriend.
当然，当你像这样回到过去时，你会发现你的记忆是多么片面和不完整。首先有些事实你记错了。结果苏珊当保姆时是大学一年级，而不是我想象的高中。我姐姐记得她骑过摩托车。这也不是真的。那个因为猫而吵架的家伙，在我印象里是她70年代毛茸茸的男朋友，结果却是她室友的男朋友。
But besides the facts you change, there are the facts you completely omit. That fight over the cats? Susan had forgotten totally that I'd been there. And it was a little strange, because my presence was the only thing she'd forgotten. Other details she remembered fine, even the names of the cats themselves.
除了你记错的事实，还有你完全遗漏的事实。那场关于猫的争吵？苏珊完全忘记了我当时也在场。而这有点奇怪，因为我的出现是她唯一忘记的事情。其他细节她记得很清楚，甚至连猫的名字都记得。
Possum and Tom. We were hillbillies, remember? But I can't imagine what I took you over there for.
负鼠和汤姆。我们当时是乡下人，记得吗？但我无法想象我带你去那儿干什么。
I'm sure it was for-- I think we were just running errands.
我敢打赌是为了——我想我们只是在办杂事。
You're so lucky.
你太幸运了。
It's funny, because when I-- like, you know, I remember these very particular incidents. And that was one of them. And probably the reason I remember it is because it seemed very significant to you. I think I sensed, as a kid, that it was really upsetting to you because it-- I think I felt at that time that you didn't really have very many people in your life, at that point, who you could trust.
这很有趣，因为当我也——你知道，我记得那些非常具体的事件。那是其中之一。我记得它的原因可能就是因为它对你来说似乎意义重大。我想我在孩提时代感觉到，那对你来说真的很令人不安，因为它——我想我当时觉得那时候你生命中并没有多少你可以信任的人。
Oh, I didn't have hardly anybody. My whole family moved out of town. I had no family at all. I moved out the day I graduated from high school. And I was 17, because I started a year early. I just wanted out. And see, I had found out that I got the scholarship. I packed up that night.
噢，我几乎没什么人能信任。我的全家都搬出城了。我一个家人都没有。我高中毕业那天就搬走了。我当时才17岁，因为我提前一年上学。我只是想出去。你看，我当时发现我拿到了奖学金。那天晚上我就收拾好行李了。
Why did you want to get out so bad?
你为什么那么想出去？
Because my family was dysfunctional. But my mom-- it was pretty bad.
因为我的家庭功能失调。但我妈——情况很糟糕。
The girl that I lived with-- at that time, she was taking a lot of drugs. And her boyfriend. And every time I would come home, they would always try to get me to take drugs with them or something. And I really didn't do it much at all. And it was really tough to come home.
和我住在一起的那个女孩——当时，她吸了很多毒。还有她男朋友。每次我回家，他们总是试图拉我一起吸毒之类的。我真的没怎么做。回家真的很艰难。
And I guess I must have been suffering a little bit. I really missed my little brothers and my little sister, and they were gone. And I was, I guess, maybe trying to substitute.
我猜我当时肯定有点痛苦。我真的很想念我的小弟弟小妹妹们，他们都离开了。而我，我猜，也许在试图找人替代。
I think maybe that's one of the reasons that I remember, that we remember you so fondly, though. Because I think it worked both ways. I think that we felt-- that that did make you feel closer to us. I think that we responded.
我觉得这可能就是为什么我们那么怀念你，因为我认为这是双向的。我觉得我们感受到了——那确实让你感觉和我们更亲近。我想我们做出了回应。
Well, I was desparately-- I guess I was looking for a family. But I mean, if only you knew, you probably wouldn't have hired me. But I mean, people are complicated.
嗯，我当时非常——我猜我在寻找一个家。但是我是说，如果你们知道真相，你们可能就不会雇我了。但是我是说，人都是复杂的。
Now, what I really wanted to do was spend more time with your mom and dad. But I was terrified. I mean, I just couldn't do it. I was too shy. So a lot of times-- I thought they were asking me to stay longer and talk and I would just run out.
现在，我真正想做的是花更多时间和你父母在一起。但我很害怕。我是说，我就是做不到。我太害羞了。所以很多时候——我觉得他们是想让我多待一会儿聊聊，但我只是直接跑了。
I'm sure they were.
我敢肯定他们是的。
And they probably thought, what's wrong with her? But I just couldn't do it.
他们可能在想，她怎么了？但我就是做不到。
So you sort of talked to us instead, sounds like.
所以听起来你反倒是跟我们交流更多。
Yeah. I was comfortable around kids because I had kids in my family.
是的。我和孩子在一起很自在，因为我家里就有孩子。
Every time the subject of her hard times came up, I'd hear a subtle hesitancy in Susan's voice. At first I thought it was embarrassment, but that wasn't it, exactly. It wasn't until we'd been talking for hours that I realized what it was.
每当她艰难时期的主题出现，我就能在苏珊的声音里听到一种细微的犹豫。起初我以为是尴尬，但并不完全是这样。直到我们谈了几个小时后，我才意识到那是什么。
She was waiting for the other shoe to drop. She hasn't forgotten that her past had happened. She'd just forgotten that I'd witnessed part of it. And her fear became clear, the one that had been gnawing at her our entire conversation, was that I was calling to say she damaged me by exposing me to it.
她在等着另一只鞋掉下来。她没忘记她的过去曾经发生过。她只是忘记了我曾见证过其中的一部分。她的恐惧变得清晰起来，那个在她整个谈话过程中一直啃噬着她的恐惧，就是我打电话来是为了说她通过让我接触那些经历而伤害了我。
I don't think I was too kind back then. Because there was a lot of turmoil in my life and in my family. And that's what my fear is, that I might have had some kind of negative impact on people. And I know probably I did, on a couple people. But they were my age. But you just want to remember, yeah, I was the babysitter. The kids loved me. Blah blah blah. I would be devastated if I heard anything different.
我那时候不太善良。因为我的生活和家庭里有很多动荡。而这就是我的恐惧，我可能给别人带来了一些负面影响。我知道我可能确实对几个人产生了影响。但他们也是我这个年纪。但你只想记得，是的，我是那个保姆。孩子们爱我。叽里呱啦。如果我听到任何不同的说法，我会崩溃的。
There are parts of your past you don't want to go back to, parts of yourself you don't want to go back to. And for Susan Jordan, the year of her life that I remember is the year she'd just as soon forget.
你过去的一些部分你不想回去，你过去的一些自我你不想回去。对于苏珊·乔丹来说，我记得的那一年，是她宁愿忘记的一年。
And it turns out, I had also done my best to forget what I was like that year. I didn't think of myself this way at all, but Susan Jordan reminded me in the gentlest terms possible. When I was nine, I was anxious and bookish. I was kind of uptight.
事实证明，我也尽了最大努力去忘记那一年我是什么样的。我根本没把自己想成那样，但苏珊·乔丹以最温柔的方式提醒了我。9岁时，我很焦虑，书呆子气。我很拘谨。
Not to seem as an insult, but I just kept thinking, these kids don't know how to play. When I went to your rooms, it didn't seem like you had a whole lot of toys. I hope I've got this right. But it just seemed like there were mostly books and more educational things. I mean, I remember you had planets in your room and a chemistry set. And I didn't remember that Kate had hardly any dolls. You didn't seem quite as playful as other kids that I had babysat. Just more serious in general. So mainly, I think that's what I did, was try to play.
并不是要侮辱，但我只是不停地想，这些孩子怎么都不会玩啊。当我走进你们的房间，看起来你们并没有很多玩具。希望我没记错。但似乎大多是书和教育类东西。我是说，我记得你们房里有行星模型和化学实验套件。我不记得凯特有什么洋娃娃。你们看起来不像我照顾过的其他孩子那样爱玩。总的来说更严肃一点。所以我想，我主要做的就是试图去玩。
Perhaps the most amazing thing about this whole story is how little our memories have deceived us about each other, even if they had deceived us about ourselves. As Susan said at one point, each of us remembered what we needed to about the other. I needed to remember the part of Susan that she doesn't think about much. Her toughness in the face of hardship. She said she mostly remembered a side of my family that I just take for granted-- that it was calm in our house. That there were books. There wasn't much fighting.
关于整个故事，最奇妙的事情也许是我们对彼此的记忆有多么没有欺骗我们，即使我们在对自己这部分有过欺骗。正如苏珊曾说过的那样，我们每个人都记住了关于对方所需要记住的东西。我需要记住苏珊不怎么想的那些部分。她在逆境面前的坚韧。她说她主要记得我家的一面，那种我视为理所当然的一面——我们家很安静。有很多书。没怎么打架。
It was the first time in my life where I had ever seen that people lived differently than the way I lived. And that's what I decided I wanted for myself.
那是我一生中第一次看到人们的生活方式与我不同。那就是我决定为自己争取的东西。
You can try to return to childhood by looking at photos, or visiting the old neighborhood, or listening to recordings. Or you can find someone who knew you back then, someone you haven't seen since. They still carry within themselves a picture of you that's unclouded by the years in between. They'll remember you better than you remember yourself, and you can do the same thing for them.
你可以通过查看照片、访问旧街区或听录音来重返童年。或者你可以找到一个当年认识你的人，一个你后来再没见过的人。他们身上依然带着一张未被中间岁月所模糊的关于你的照片。他们会比你自己更好地记住你，你也能为他们做同样的事。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格。
Act Four. Every Day I Forget Something Else.
第四幕：我每天都在遗忘。
Let's end our program today with one of the ideas we began it with. Remember Kayla, the seventh greater who is already aware of how she cannot remember her own past? Well, this very idea comes up in a novel by Nicholson Baker, a really great and unusual novel called The Everlasting Story of Nory. The book is told from the point of view of a nine year old named Nory who, at some point, talks about how hard it is to remember things. Actress Michelle Trachtenberg reads a brief passage for us.
今天让我们以我们开始时的想法来结束节目。还记得凯拉吗？那个已经意识到自己无法记住过去七年的七年级学生？这个想法出现在尼科尔森·贝克的一本小说里，一本非常伟大且独特的小说，叫《诺里的永恒故事》。这本书是从一个叫诺里的9岁女孩的角度讲述的，她在某个时候谈到了记住事情有多难。演员米歇尔·特拉亨伯格为我们读了一段。
That afternoon, Nory tried to reconstruct every tiny detail of the International Chinese School in her mind. She couldn't even remember all the kids in the class. She remembered one very nice girl named Stephie, who left later on, who had a birthday party at her swimming pool where Nory had floundered into the deep end and had gotten about a gallon and a half of water in her lungs and thrown up a tiny bit on the grass.
那天下午，诺里试图在脑海中重建国际中文学校的每一个微小细节。她甚至记不起班上所有的孩子。她记得一个叫史蒂芬妮的非常好的女孩，她后来离开了，在史蒂芬妮家的游泳池办过生日派对，当时诺里曾扑腾进了深水区，肺里大概呛了一加仑半的水，还在草地上吐了一点点。
She gave Stephie a pair of tiny glass slippers wrapped up in probably the best wrapping paper she had ever drawn. She still thought about those glass slippers. They were paperweights that a glassblower made, but they worked as real doll shoes. They were amazingly wonderful.
她给了史蒂芬妮一对小玻璃拖鞋，包在她画过的最好的包装纸里。她依然经常想起那双玻璃拖鞋。它们是玻璃吹制工做的镇纸，但确实能当真正的玩偶鞋穿。它们美妙得令人惊叹。
It disturbed Nory very much to think that all she was going to know about what happened in her life was not very much at all. You can only really remember the things that happened when you were an older child and the things that happened to you now. That is, yesterday, or the day before yesterday, or late last week.
想到她余生能知道的关于自己经历的事情其实寥寥无几，这让诺里感到非常不安。你只能真正记住你作为大孩子时发生的事情，以及现在发生在你身上的事情。也就是昨天，或者前天，或者是上周晚些时候。
You live your life always in the present, and even in the present, this day, dozens and hundreds of little tiny things happen. So many that by the end of the day, you can't make a list of them. You lose track of them unless something reminds you. Say someone says, remember when you dropped your ruler this morning? And you do remember. But then that is lost in the tangle.
你总是生活在当下，即使是在当下，这一天也会发生几十、几百件小事。太多了，以至于到了一天结束时，你无法列出清单。除非有什么东西提醒你，否则你会失去对它们的追踪。比如有人说，还记得你今天早上弄掉尺子的时候吗？你就记得了。但随后那又消失在错综复杂的记忆里。
Now, some things you can just accept that you're not going to have the slightest chance of remembering. It would be nice, but you know that it would be basically impossible. For instance, being in your mother's womb, as it's called. Some people thought babies could remember that.
当然，有些事情你可以坦然接受，你是绝不可能记住的。如果能记住当然好，但你知道那基本上是不可能的。比如所谓的在母亲的子宫里。有些人以为婴儿能记得那个。
Nory one morning asked Littleguy if he could remember being tucked away in mommy's belly long ago, and he said, "Yes." He said, "It had all things there, in she's tummy. It had things that were called steam trains. It was filled with they. Filled with steam trains, city of Truro, Lord of the Isles, the Mallard. Pictures with steam trains, and toy ones, and jumping things. Filled, filled with they."
有一天早上，诺里问小家伙他是否还能记得很久以前蜷缩在妈咪肚子里，他说：“记得。”他说：“那里什么都有，在她的肚子里。有叫蒸汽火车的东西。到处都是。充满了它们。充满蒸汽火车，特鲁罗城，岛屿之主，野鸭号。照片里有蒸汽火车，玩具火车，还有跳动的物体。充满，充满了它们。”
Well, of course there weren't toy trains in Nory's mother's womb, unless maybe he was a remembering the small intestine chuffing around. Maybe he was remembering a freight train of food being digested, going around and around him. But probably not.
好吧，当然诺里的母亲子宫里没有玩具火车，除非也许他在记得小肠在呼哧呼哧地蠕动。也许他记得的是一列食物运送的货运列车正在消化中绕着他转。但很可能不是。
Still, Nory thought it would be nice if you could think back at least to the age of three. It shouldn't be impossible. Three was older than Littleguy, and Littleguy could understand an amazing number of things. But Nory couldn't go back that far, really, except for a few scribs and scraps. She remembered being eight, and back into being seven, and she went pretty much back to five, and then it teetered a little bit. She only remembered her fourth birthday party, a mermaid party, because she had watched the tape of it a number of times on TV.
不过，诺里还是觉得如果能回想到3岁大就好了。那不应该是不可能的。3岁比小家伙大，小家伙都能理解惊人数量的事情。但诺里真的回不到那么久以前，除了一些零碎的记忆。她记得8岁，追溯到7岁，她基本上能回到5岁，然后就开始摇摇欲坠了。她只记得她4岁生日派对，那个美人鱼主题派对，因为她在电视上看过很多次派对的录像。
One thing, though, she made a point of remembering and passing onto her older self. Every year she got a year older, she said to her parents, "Remember when I was five, I said I was five going on six? Remember when I was six, I said six going on seven? And when I was seven, I'd be going seven on eight. And then going on eight, on nine? Well, now I'm going nine on ten." So each year, the list of years got a little longer. But she remembered the earlier times that way by saying the list over.
不过，有一件事她确实设法记住并传递给年长的自己。每年她大一岁，她就会对父母说：“还记得我5岁时说我5岁快6岁了吗？记得我6岁时说6岁快7岁吗？7岁时我会说7岁快8岁？然后快8岁，9岁？好吧，现在我是9岁快10岁了。”所以每年，年份清单都会长一点点。但她通过不断重复那个清单，记住了早先的时光。
Another thing she made sure to bring along every year with her for a long time was the memory that there were many, many little amounts of money that she had found in the car and thought could be hers, but maybe not. Or times her parents had bought her a doll outfit or something when she told him she would reimburse them later, when they got home, with her own money. Or gifts she bought other people with her own money. But borrowing it from her parents, since she'd forgotten her purse. She would skip a week, not thinking to it, then still remember it, and bring it into the next week. Then skip a week, then bring it over.
她每年很长一段时间里确保随身带着的另一件事是，她曾在车里发现过很多很多少量的钱，以为那些钱可能是她的，但也可能不是。或者她的父母曾给她买过一套玩偶服，而当她告诉父母回家后会用自己的钱还给他们时。或者她用自己的钱给别人买礼物。但既然她忘记了钱包，她是从父母那里借的钱。她会跳过一周，不往那方面想，然后依然记得它，把它带到下一周。然后再跳过一周，然后再带过去。
Finally, she couldn't keep the amount in her head, because it had been added onto and subtracted from so much. And it began to pull at her. And she thought, "I know. I'll pay them $100 when I grow up, and that will surely make up for anything I've borrowed along the way. Then she didn't have to keep track of that.
最后，她无法在脑海里记下那个数额，因为它被加加减减了太多次。它开始让她感到困扰。她想：“我知道了。我长大后会还他们100美元，这肯定能抵消我一路借来的任何东西。那样我就不用追踪它了。”
Michelle Trachtenberg, who plays Buffy's little sister and a portal and a key on the TV show Buffy the Vampire Slayer, reading an except from Nicholson Baker's Everlasting Story of Nory.
米歇尔·特拉亨伯格，在《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》中饰演巴菲的妹妹、通道和钥匙的演员，阅读尼科尔森·贝克的《诺里的永恒故事》片段。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Goldstein and myself with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, Starlee Kine, Erin Yanke, and Annie Baxter. Senior producer Julie Snyder, consigliere Sarah Vowell, production help from Todd Bachmann.
好了，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·戈尔茨坦和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、蓝·切维尼、斯塔莉·凯恩、艾琳·扬克和安妮·巴克斯特参与。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德，顾问萨拉·沃威尔，托德·巴赫曼提供制作帮助。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who you know, he tells me, he has played Japan, too. He swears.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，你知道吗，他告诉我，他也去过日本。我发誓。
I'd forgotten what it was to have the audience right there.
我忘记了那种观众就在台下的感觉。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给您更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。